liebe kolleginnen und kollegen guten
morgen aus der bundespressekonferenz am
freitag mit in einer inzwischen quasi
traditionell gewordenen pressekonferenz
zur corona lage zu der wir uns freuen
erneut bundesgesundheitsminister jens
spahn zu begrüßen
auch den präsidenten des
robert-koch-instituts lothar wieler und
daneben heute zu gast ist angerichtet er
sie es vorstandsmitglied im
hausärzteverband westfalen lippe und
leiterin des zentrums im kreis minden
lübbecke und kann dazu berichten
wir werden von allen dreien kurze
statements hören bevor wir wie gewohnt
zu ihren fragen kommen
ich erinnere noch mal daran dass wir uns
in corona zeiten bemühen die
pressekonferenzen auf eine stunde zu
begrenzen
aus gegebenem anlass empfehle ich auch
die handys auszuschalten und dann
starten die rund ersparen hat das wort
so traurig dass er meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren die lage bleibt
angespannt die fallzahlen steigen wieder
langsam zwar aber sie steigen und in
gotha zion breiten sich aus das heißt
wir müssen uns noch auf einige sehr
herausfordernde wochen einstellen in
denen wir weiter ringen um die richtige
balance zwischen dem notwendigen
gesundheitsschutz und der normalität
nach der wir uns alle zu sehen
wir sollten allerdings auch wahrnehmen
wo sich die dinge verbessert haben
wir konnten bereits die meisten
bürgerinnen und bürger bewohnerinnen und
bewohner in pflegeheimen impfen
viele der über 80 jährigen konnten
bereits geimpft werden oder haben
zeitnahen impftermin in einigen ländern
bereits die ersten über 70-jährigen die
zahl der infektionen der
krankenhausbehandlung und der zu
beklagenden todesfälle gerade bei den
höchst betagten und älteren gehen
deutlich zurück
pflegeheime können auch zug um zug ihre
strikten isolations und besuchs regeln
lockern wie nordrhein-westfalen ist
beispielsweise gerade macht
und im übrigen auch das finde ich
sollten wir gelegentlich wahrnehmen wenn
wir schauen über die letzten fünf sechs
monate im europäischen vergleich
gibt es wenige länder unserer größe und
geografischen lage die während der
ganzen zweiten welle im unteren drittel
beim infektionsgeschehen und bei der
dynamik gewesen sind bei allen was
besser geht und bei allem was wir auch
betrachten müssen wo wir
infektionsgeschehen noch besser in den
griff bekommen müssen wir haben im
europäischen vergleich bis hierhin auch
in der zweiten welle viele viele bürger
vorerkrankungen die schwersten verläufen
schützen können auch deshalb und weil
wir nicht länger im absoluten lockdown
erstarren können haben sich bund und
länder zu vorsichtigen öffnung schritten
entschieden ist an die grenze dessen das
sagte ich bereits letzte woche was aus
sicht des gesundheitsschutzes
verantwortbar ist
daher testen von umsicht dieser
dreiklang wird und muss uns dabei
begleiten
das sind kurz zum testen und zum impfen
zum testen
diese woche haben bereits viele länder
und viele landkreise und städte in
deutschland mit den schnelltests für
alle mit den bürger tests begonnen
gemessen auch an der kritischen
öffentlichen debatte ist das ein erfolg
der bund zahlt den test mindestens
einmal pro woche den länder und kommunen
die testzentren vor ort besorgen die
schnelltests umbauen schritt für schritt
die infrastruktur auf das funktioniert
noch unterschiedlich gut aber es
funktioniert und es funktioniert an ganz
vielen stellen im land auch schon sehr
gut und gemessen daran nimmt sich ja
sehen wir am mittwoch nacht eine
entscheidung der ministerpräsidenten
konferenz gehabt wir haben noch in der
nacht begonnen die abstimmung zur
verordnung bis sonntag fertig gestellt
jetzt sind wir am freitag danach und in
zumindest sehr vielen teilen des landes
klappt es schon mit dem umfassenden
schnelltest angebot mit dem bürger test
und in den landkreisen und städten wo es
noch im aufbau ist ist es ins bett und
war auch für nächste woche schon
angekündigt und vom letzten mittwoch bis
heute finde ich ist das schon ein
enormer erfolg und frau richter sind der
nicht nur im zentrum sondern als ärztin
auch beim testen mit eingebunden was ich
wichtig finde ist dass wir die wirkung
der schnelltests wie der testung
insgesamt auf dem
im verlauf nicht überschätzen sie sind
ein wichtiges instrument aber sie lösen
auch nicht alle fragen es ist weiterhin
wichtig auch die anderen regeln abstand
hygiene medizinische schutzmasken
einzuhalten
wir sehen im übrigen auch in unseren
nachbarländern auch die auch schon viel
testen das testen alleine den pandemie
verlauf nicht unter kontrolle bringt es
geht im übrigen auch für selbsttests es
wird bald das erste dutzend an
selbsttests in deutschland zugelassen
sein
sie kommen immer mehr auch in die
versorgung beziehungsweise in den alltag
da sollen sie vor allem hin in den kitas
und schulen in den betrieben und eben
auch für den selbst gebrauch im
einzelhandel
ich habe letzte woche freitag angeboten
mitzuhelfen dafür zu sorgen dass die
länder tatsächlich für kitas und schulen
auch tests bestellen können
die ersten sind an mit am mittwoch vor
gestern ausgeliefert worden aus dieser
ankündigung aus den verträgen die wir
als rahmenverträge geschlossen haben als
bunt und es wird weitere folgen können
wir haben ein weiteres angebot an die
länder geschickt bis zu 62 millionen
selbst testete märz und april jetzt
kurzfristig auch mit ersten lieferungen
abgesichert so dass die brücke ist die
ausschreibung der länder selbst der für
kitas und schulen in ausschreibungen
sind dass wir diese brücke bauen können
das eben sehr zügig wie gesagt vor zwei
tagen die erste auslieferung daneben
auch tests verfügbar sind
zum impfen über sieben prozent der
deutschen sind einmal mindestens geimpft
sind über oder um die sechs millionen
wir haben übrigens erstmalig jetzt
tageshöchstwerte bei den täglichen
impfungen erreicht
in den letzten zwei tagen jeweils über
270.000 impfungen pro tag jeweils
200.000 erstimpfung pro tag etwa wir
sehen also es gewinnt deutlich an
dynamik
ich habe gestern hier in berlin eine
haushalts praxis oder eine arztpraxis
besucht dort wird im rahmen eines
modellprojektes jetzt wie 100 über 100
anderen praxen auch hier in berlin
geimpft in der arztpraxis und was noch
dell ist soll die regel werden die
gesundheitsministerinnen minister von
bund und länder haben dafür ein
beschluss erarbeitet so früh wie möglich
spätestens aber mitte april sollen auch
niedergelassene ärzte routinemäßig in
die korona impfkampagne einbezogen
werden
immer mit dem wichtigen hinweis wenn die
lieferungen wie zugesagt erfolgen
warum nicht früher fragen viele weil die
länder und die kommunen vor ort auch die
impfzentren weiter laufen lassen wollen
und weil es noch nicht genug impfstoff
gibt um alle impfzentren und parallel
alle arztpraxen zu versorgen
der wechsel in die arztpraxen ist ein
entscheidender schritt ist der
grundstein und deutlich an
geschwindigkeit gewinnen zu können
es wird zu sein dass wenn am sonntag
beispielsweise schreiben über den ablauf
am sonntag ausgeliefert wird an den
großhandel wahrscheinlich bis
montagmittag nachmittag in allen
apotheken und arztpraxen in deutschland
es ist ja ein sehr ausgefeiltes
logistikkonzept jeden tag wo apotheken
in deutschland drei bis fünfmal am tag
ja heute schon beliefert werden und
genau auf diesem wege werden auch die
impfstoffe in den praxis in die praxen
kommen sodass dann an dem montag die
arztpraxen geliefert sind und ich sehr
sicher bin dass dann fast in beliebiger
menge was wir liefern können die
arztpraxen dann bis zum freitag samstag
verläuft haben werden so dass wir dann
eben tatsächlich eine in eine deutlich
andere dynamik kommen können wenn
ausreichend impfstoffe dafür da sind
anders als gedacht werden wir allerdings
nicht
oder als einige denken gleich auf
priorisierung verzichten können gerade
die zahlen bei den über 80-jährigen
zeigen wie wichtig ist war und ist zu
priorisieren hätten wir nicht zuerst die
pflege heimbewohnerinnen und bewohner
und die besonders gefährdeten nämlich
die hochbetagten geimpft hätten wir
weniger menschen geschützt vor
schwersten und tödlichen verläufen in
den letzten wochen
deswegen ist es grundsätzlich weiterhin
wichtig bei noch knappen impfstoffen zu
priorisieren
wir können aber mit jedem schritt und
mit wachsender menge die übergänge
fließend gestalten und gerade für
menschen mit vorerkrankungen
ist natürlich das impfen in den praxen
eigentlich der ideale ort weil die
ärztin und ärzte ihre patienten kennen
und da habe ich auch großes vertrauen in
die ärzte und ärzte dass sie genau das
auch so umsetzen wollen sie wollen am
ende ihre patienten und die besonders
verwundbaren unter ihnen als erstes auch
schützen
danke dann herr wähler haben sie das
wort ja guten tag meine damen und herren
zu beginn dieses jahres ist es uns sehr
gut gelungen die fallzahl zu reduzieren
aber die pandemie ist natürlich leider
noch nicht vorbei und im gegenteil jetzt
stehen wir am anfang der dritten welle
und diese dritte welle müssen wir
gemeinsam so flach halten wie möglich
denn das geht nur wenn wir ansteckungen
verhindern wenn wir verhindern dass die
fallzahlen wieder explodieren und dann
können wir gemeinsam verhindern dass wir
in die gleiche situation kommen wie vor
weihnachten mit vielen erkrankungen mit
vielen schweren verläufen und auch mit
vielen todesfällen und einem
gesundheitssystem das sehr stark
belastet ist
die impfungen weisen uns den weg aus der
pandemie aber bis der großteil der
menschen geimpft ist wird es noch eine
weile dauern bis dahin bitte ich uns
alle halten wir uns weiter an die hhl
regeln reduzieren wir weiter waren immer
möglich unsere kontakte und wenn wir
symptome einer akuten atemwegsinfektion
zeigen dann bitte bleiben wir auch zu
hause und rufen einen arzt an
wenn wir uns die situation in
deutschland anschauen dann sehen wir
dass sich die fallzahlen seit einiger
zeit auf einem zu hohen niveau
eingependelt haben bei den unter 60
jährigen steigt die instanz zu kaufen
haben und seit mitte februar steigt auch
die inzidenz bei den unter 15-jährigen
und zwar sehr rasant wir sehen auch
wieder mehr kita ausbrüche sogar noch
mehr als vor weihnachten
es könnte sein dass hier die noch
ansteckende variante b 11 7
eine rolle spielt bei 117 breitet sich
ja insgesamt sehr rasch in deutschland
aus von den schweren akuten
atemwegsinfektionen
im krankenhaus behandelt werden müssen
gehen auch wieder mehr auf cupid 19
zurück der anteil war eigentlich in den
letzten wochen stetig gesunken
auch die zahl der patienten auf den
intensivstationen nimmt in einigen
bundesländern wieder leicht zu und wir
sehen leider immer noch zu viele
todesfälle in verbindung mit 19
auch wenn die zahlen glücklicherweise
momentan weiter sinken
die impfung ist neben unseren
verantwortungsvollen persönlichen
verhalten die impfung ist das mächtigste
werkzeug das wir haben
wir sehen dass die fallzahlen bei den
ältesten menschen die lange sehr schwer
betroffen waren zurückgehen das ist ein
großartiger erfolg und er zeigt dass es
richtig und wichtig war die ältesten
menschen zuerst zu impfen das ziel ist
ja bei begrenzter menge an impfstoff so
viele schwere verläufe und todesfälle
wie möglich zu verhindern leben zu
retten und das ist uns gelungen
das alter ist der wesentliche
risikofaktor je weniger ältere menschen
überhaupt erst krank werden desto
weniger erkrankten schwer oder sterben
sogar wir sehen im moment dass die zahl
der todesfälle kontinuierlich zurückgeht
das ist sicher auch ein effekt der
impfungen aber noch immer sind sehr
viele menschen nicht geimpft
ich freue mich aber auch sehr dass sie
schon bald sehr viel mehr menschen
impfen lassen können auch mit hilfe der
hausärzte und dann bald auch der
betriebsärzte und bei denen möchte mir
jetzt schon für ihre bereitschaft und
ihr engagement in dieser sache sehr
herzlich bedanken
meine damen und herren ein weiteres
neues werkzeug in unserem werkzeugkasten
sind die selbsttests sie können dazu
beitragen die pandemie zu bekämpfen wenn
mehr infektionen gefunden werden können
und weil sie auch schneller gefunden
werden können
dafür muss man sie aber auch wirklich
verantwortungsvoll einsetzen
ein negatives selbst testergebnis
bedeutet nicht dass man frei getestet
ist so ein test ist nur eine
momentaufnahme man kann trotzdem
ansteckend sein oder kurz danach
ansteckend werden
deshalb ist es sehr wichtig dass man
sich trotzdem weiter an die asl regeln
hält bei einem positiven testergebnis
bleiben sie bitte unbedingt zu hause und
rufen sie eine arztpraxis oder im
testzentrum an positive selbsttests
ergebnisse sollten immer durch eine pcr
bestätigt wird und ganz unabhängig vom
selbst testergebnis gilt immer wenn sie
symptome einer akuten atemwegsinfektion
haben bleiben sie zu hause und rufen sie
ihre arztpraxis
ich hatte es anfangs gesagt die pandemie
ist noch nicht vorbei wir laufen einen
marathon
wir befinden uns im letzten drittel und
das ist bekanntermaßen besonders
anstrengend auch weil jetzt noch ein
wettlauf gegen die varianten dazu
gekommen ist
mit hilfe der impfung werden wir bald
auf der zielgeraden sein
wir werden in eine neue phase der
pandemie eintreten von der bekämpfung
hin zu einer kontrolle des virus hinzu
control kowitz das virus wird nicht mehr
verschwinden
aber wenn wir eine grundimmunisierung
haben dann können wir das virus
kontrollieren als gesellschaft werden
wir lernen damit umzugehen
das ist das ziel und wir werden es
gemeinsam erreichen das beste was jeder
von uns bis dahin tun kann ist aktiv zur
eindämmung des virus beizutragen
wenn sie mit anderen menschen mit
innenräumen zusammenkommen tragen sie wo
immer möglich masken und lüften sie
machen sie vom selbst test- und schnell
test angebot gebrauch und helfen sie du
hier selbstverantwortliches handeln
infektionskette zu unterbrechen
bleiben sie bei positiven test zu hause
isolierung und ruft sie einen arzt an
ist ihr positives testangebot ergebnis
bestätigt benachrichtungen sie umgehend
ihre engen kontakte damit diese sich
ebenfalls in quarantäne begeben können
jeder und jede von uns kann so aktiv das
virus und die ausbreitung des virus
unterbinden der beste schutz meine damen
und herren für uns alle ist eine
niedrige incidents danke und
abschließend traurig dass er minister
schmalfuß
herr professor wieder sehr geehrte damen
und herren ja wie sie die rolle der
hausärzte in dieser situation an auf
jeden fall sind wir an der basis und
müssen vielen erlassen oder vielen
anordnung einfach auch folgen und auch
umsetzen und hier und da sicherlich auch
mal kritisch hinterfragen dass wir
hausärzte für die sicherung der
patienten zuständig sind das ist jedem
klar dass wissen wir auch und im
zusammenhang mit den testungen sichern
wir auch die patientenversorgung schon
monatelang in dem wir grippale infekte
versuchen wird oder nicht versuchen zu
testen
kontaktpersonen testen und auch manchmal
bestimmte berufsgruppen dort wo sie sich
eben an bietet jetzt kommen die neuen
tests zu dass eben jeder bürger einmal
wöchentlich die möglichkeit hat sich
testen zu lassen
dort gibt es das öffentliche
gesundheitswesen ist dafür in erster
linie zuständig aber auch wir hausärzte
dürfen ist auf freiwilliger basis machen
wir werden das auf jeden fall machen für
unsere eigenen patienten der eine mehr
der andere weniger denn man muss sagen
diese testungen sind natürlich neben dem
normalen praxisbetrieb auch stellen eine
gewisse logistische herausforderung wir
brauchen mehr wartezimmer wir brauchen
sicherlich wenn auch eine mitarbeiterin
die das durchführt das bedeutet schon
testungen in größerer anzahl muss man
zum beispiel sollte man außerhalb der
sprechstundenzeiten machen aber das ist
nicht so sehr das thema ich sage immer
wenn es da ist werden wir uns schon was
einfallen lassen
wichtig in diesem zusammenhang ist aber
auch aktuell das bis dato die nach die
resonanz seitens der praxen gar nicht so
groß war ich habe mich also für heute
noch mal einige kollegen angerufen die
kollegen sagen es läuft sehr schleppend
an
es kommen einige patienten aber eben
noch wenig und dann muss man sich
natürlich fragen welche patienten kommen
und das sieht man schon dass das
patienten sind die auch verantwortung
der umgebung gegenüber haben das sind
ältere patienten die wiederum pflegende
angehörige pflegende person zu hause
haben die lassen sich impfen oder album
auch ängstliche menschen die viel durch
beruf durch wodurch auch immer kontakt
zu anderen menschen haben also die tests
sind sicherlich ein schritt auch um
diese pandemie mit einzugrenzen
wir werden das sicherlich aus
ärztlicherseits auch unterstützen
aber ich sag mal ich glaube da liegt das
meiste in den test
die zentren seitens des öffentlichen
gesundheitswesen um die masse zumindest
damit durchzubekommen
das zweite thema das impfen ja das ist
dann für uns hausärzte schon etwas
spannender auf jedes jahr seit monaten
die bevölkerung schnellstmöglichst durch
zu impfen
ich denke dass es mit dem start der
impfzentren auch sehr gut gelungen wir
haben einen großteil der über
80-jährigen ist mittlerweile schon durch
games man hat zumindest das gefühl wenn
man jeden tag die über 80-jährigen sieht
die auch bei wind und wetter der erste
tag war ja nicht so schön
dank des schneegestöbers ins zentrum
kommen also von daher gesehen ist das
eine sicherlich sehr gute sache und
aktuell geht es ja weiter dass wir
bestimmte berufsgruppen impfen die wir
zb in dieser menge auch in den
hausarztpraxen zum beispiel nicht
zufrieden stellen könnten wir haben
aktuell eine berufsgruppe mit über 380
personen die wir binnen einer woche
durch impfen sollen wir machen das im
moment morgens mit 50 personen von 8 bis
9 uhr
ja das wüsste ich nicht wie ich das
hinaus als praxis unterkriegen sollte
also die impfzentren sind da auf jeden
fall da aber die hausarztpraxen müssen
auch aus ärztlicher sicht so schnell wie
möglich jetzt mit 1 infocom warum impfen
ist eine ureigene sache von uns das
machen wir tagtäglich wir sind es
gewohnt auch da sage ich mal massen zu
impfen ich denke jetzt gerade an die
influenza saison im letzten jahr auch da
haben wir gezeigt wie schnell wird durch
impfen können
das heißt warum soll man dank die
bestehenden strukturen einfach auch
nutzen
das ist also wie gesagt auf jeden fall
da und vor allem es gibt noch einen ganz
anderen aspekt der mir als ärztliche
leitung in meinem kreisgebiet erst
bewusst geworden ist wir fangen jetzt an
dass wir nicht nur die höchste
priorisierung gruppe impfen sondern es
kommen ja auch durch gleichstellungs
anträge kommen ja auch menschen dann in
die höhere gruppe und meinen dann sie
könnten geimpft werden also ich habe
tagtäglich sind mindestens 30 40
personen die nur kommen vom mail verkehr
ganz abgesehen
die dann ganz stolz ihr attest in der
hand haben ja schutzimpfung motor
priorisierung nach § 3 ziffer xy nach
der korona virus impfverordnung dann
stehen wieder ja und jetzt darf ich gelb
werden kann ich nicht das ist für mich
aus ärztlicher leitung nur dieses attest
ist eine standard information dass er
jetzt gleich gestellt wird also erkläre
ich den patienten so sie sind aber jetzt
mal höher gerutscht ich brauche ein
qualifiziertes zeugnis ich brauche eine
individuelle test von ihrem hausarzt
dann sind dement diese menschen sind
enttäuscht sind traurig weil sie mit
viel hoffnung in das zentrum gekommen
sind und auch für die hausärzte
qualifiziertes zeugnis zu erstellen ja
gut das müssen wir dann natürlich machen
machen wir auch aber dann kann man sich
auch fragen warum impfen wir nicht
selber und es wäre eben aus unserer
sicht schon zu fordern nicht nur mitte
april sondern ich bin schon da weiter
sich sage anfang april am liebsten noch
früher auch in die haushaltskassen denn
die priorisierung die vorgegeben ist die
ist unantastbar das ist klar aber wir
haben innerhalb der zweiten
priorisierung gruppe nämlich der
chronisch krank und unter 65 oder 65 bis
da müssen wir ja unterscheiden und ich
glaube das kann man der politik nicht
zumuten dass sie den einzelnen die
einzelnen menschen in diesen
priorisierung gruppen unterscheidet oder
differenziert ich sag jetzt mal
chronisch kranker in der priorisierung
gruppe 2 ist per definition um ein
junges mädchen mit einer unterfunktion
der schilddrüse das zelt zu chronischen
erkrankungen
ebenfalls in dieser gruppe habe ich aber
auch einen patienten mit einer
lungenfibrose und das versteht sich ja
von selbst dass ich in der
hausarztpraxis dann den patienten mit
der lungenfibrose in der impfung
vorziehe
im vergleich zu der jungen frau mit der
hypothese das darf man nicht als
priorisierung in dem sinne bezeichnet
und natürlich soll es auch nicht sein
dass wir die priorisierung die
vorgegeben ist aus dem aushebeln wollen
das auf keinen fall
aber das sind zum beispiel sachen die
ich kann ich auch als ärztliche leitung
im impfzentrum einfach nicht
bewerkstelligen ja ich kann es nicht
als hausärzte wo ich den patienten
erkennen ist das aber auf jeden fall
möglich nun also wichtig ist man wieder
dieser unterschied mehr zwischen diesen
gleichstellungs anträgen und antrag auf
vorgezogene impfung das ist durchaus
eine möglichkeit auch im zentrum zu
bewerkstelligen wenn zum beispiel jemand
kommt und sagt ich muss in vier wochen
mit einer längeren chemotherapie anfang
und soll bis dato weil auch mehrere
stationäre aufenthalte folgen bis dato
durch geimpft sein
das versteht sich von selbst dass man
diesen menschen dann die möglichkeit
gibt wenn es das kontingent hergibt
zusammengefasst auf haus als sicher sich
ja die testungen und auch die impfungen
sind sinnvoll wir alle wollen dass die
pandemie schnellstmöglichst ein ende
nimmt zu den impfungen ja auch da
schnellstmöglichst und die
hausarztpraxen aber am anfang doch noch
parallel zu den impfzentren
beispielsweise die großen berufsgruppen
die können wir in den hausarztpraxen
alleine nicht schaffen aber ansonsten
sollte doch der patient zu seinem
hausarzt gehen dürfen um sich impfen
lassen zu können was noch schön wäre
auch wenn das die herren links neben mir
nicht so gerne hören ist die
dokumentation die hätten wir gerne etwas
geschmälert
ganz kurz dann bin ich auch fertig wir
haben die größeren berufsgruppen im im
zentrum die lassen wir nicht durchgehen
checkout laufen weil das würde den
ganzen betrieb zu sehr auf halten
das heißt diese herrschaften müssen
sechs mal ihren ihre kontaktdaten
angeben mit name vorname geburtsdatum
wohnort nämlich zweimal auf der
einwilligung zweimal auf der aufklärung
und zweimal auf der imk bescheinigung
der arzt den das dann trifft der darf
dann sechsmal seine unterschrift geben
das ist dann auch immer sehr erbaulich
muss man einfach sagen für einen prozess
und dann möglicherweise noch eine siebte
zum impfpass wenn sie das für 50
personen machen die sind fast schon was
sie getan haben also man würde sich da
dass man kann es belächeln aber es sind
einfach sachen wir haben bis dato im
impfen nie im aufklärung oder einbildung
langen schon nicht mehr unterschrieben
und da darf man doch sicherlich von der
basis her die berechtigte frage stellen
ist das wirklich noch nötig dass man das
machen muss
vielen dank danke dafür dann kommen wir
zu ihren fragen ich habe mehrere im saal
schon aufgenommen nehme auch gleich noch
gerne weitere auch und habe auch online
mehrere fragen eine bitte vorab
beschränken sie sich auf eine frage was
die möglichkeit enthält eine nachfrage
zur antwort zu stellen nutzen sie die
nachfrage bitte nicht für ein zweites
thema im sinne der fairness wäre es
schön wenn wir versuchen möglichst viele
kollegen mit einer frage daran zu nehmen
ich nehme sie gern wieder auf die liste
und wenn sie die zeit ist kommen sie
auch wieder dran
die erste frage hat hier im saal hering
die frage ich kann im saarland zahlen
habe ich nicht im kopf aber die stehen
in dem bericht beziehungsweise können
sich auf der website anschauen also der
anstieg hängt nicht damit zusammen dass
mir getestet wird wir haben ja
verschiedene werkzeuge mit denen wir mit
denen wir die testung überprüfen
das mächtigste ist bestimmt zur zeit die
das sogenannte antibiotikaresistenz
waynes tool wo die labore uns alle daten
melden da sehen wir sowohl die positiven
als auch die negativen test ergebnisse
wir sehen momentan eine test glaube ich
bei etwa 6 prozent sind vom positiven
raten wir sehen nicht dass die es gibt
keinen hinweis dass eine gesteigerte
test aktivität damit zusammenhängt wir
sehen sowohl in den kitas insbesondere
bei den kleinen 0 bis 40 bis 5 jährigen
den starken anstieg wir sehen formiert
ausbrüche in kitas wir sehen dass die
ausbrüche insgesamt größer geworden sind
das heißt die anzahl der am ausbruch
beteiligten personen hat sich erhöht
es gibt hinweise dass das mit der
variante b 117 zu tun hat das sind aber
noch keine wirklich festen
aussagekräftigen daten aber es gibt
hinweise dazu wir sehen dass die
intensivbetten das ist in manchen
bundesländern dazu kommt dass sogar
schon in den intensivbetten der anstieg
der kogit 19 patienten steigt das ist ja
eigentlich das letzte signal was wir
sehen weil die hat ja die ansteckung hat
er dann vor zehn oder tagen oder drei
wochen stattgefunden das heißt also da
sehen wir sogar schon anstiege das sind
ja klinisch kranke schwerkranke menschen
die also nichts mit testung zu tun haben
sondern aufgrund der krankheit dort sind
wir sehen in einem anderen system
ich könnte noch viele nennen aber das
sprengt sicher wir sehen in einem
anderen system der anteil unter den
schweren atemwegsinfektion schwere akute
respiratorische infektion sari der
anteil derjenigen die im krankenhaus
behandelt werden steigt kontinuierlich
in den letzten wochen der anteil der
android erkrankten das heißt es gibt
eine reihe von indikatoren die drag
klinisch sind
also sehr klar belegen dass es nichts
mit testung zu tun hat sondern dass es
an steigt in bestimmten region
ich habe mit ministerpräsident hans über
saarland auch in engen austausch ist auf
dem weg zu 15 prozent südafrika variante
das ist der höchste anteil mit abstand
in ganz deutschland und aus meiner sicht
haben wir ein gemeinsames interesse
daran die britische ist auf dem weg
dominiert zu werden beziehungsweise ist
in vielen bereichen schon dominierend
dass diese variante nicht auch sich in
ganz deutschland in dieser größenordnung
ausbreitet und deswegen finde ich sehr
wichtig sie auch gemeinsam der saarland
dabei unterstützen das zu vermeiden
ich würde zum thema test zwei fragen mit
1 4 und online erreichen basil wegener
von dpa fragt herrn wieder in wie weit
sind die infektionszahlen aktuell noch
vergleichbar mit den werten aus den
wintermonaten als die zugangsschwelle
für den pcr test deutlich höher
angesetzt war und rasmus buchsteiner der
pionier fragt kann sparen und herrn
wieder bittet um eine bilanz des test
geschehens in den vergangenen tagen ist
mehr getestet worden und wie viele
selbst und schnelltests sind
ausgeliefert worden an die länder ja wie
gesagt eigentlich kann ich dir einfach
nicht sehr viel hinzufügen wir haben
natürlich angepasst sowohl an die
epidemiologische situation als auch an
die verfügbarkeit von tests die test
verordnungen die nationale test
strategie kontinuierlich überarbeitet
dass das ist auch von uns zu erwarten
das ist unser job dafür aber und das ist
das kann ich nur immer wiederholen da
wir viele verschiedene werkzeuge haben
viele verschiedene service monitoring
werkzeuge können wir das immer ins
verhältnis setzen das heißt wir können
immer sehen was der anteil der mehr
getesteten ist und der anteil des
wirklichen krankheitsgeschehens wir
haben noch weitere domains tut die
überhaupt nichts mit tests zu tun haben
zum beispiel die atemwegs
infektionsraten die in sentinel praxen
und gezeigt werden oder andere tools
wir haben nachweise von anderen
infektionserreger atemwegsinfektionen
hervor
also wir können das alles kontinuierlich
einschätzen und geben das ja auch
entsprechend in unserem täglichen tages
situationsbericht heraus also ich der
eindruck dass die anzahl der
durchgeführten tests ein korrelat dafür
ist wie viel positiv getestet wird der
ist schlichtweg nicht zutreffend und es
wäre auch schön wenn man diesen eindruck
nicht versuchen würde zu prägen weil wir
dadurch natürlich gezielt das
infektionsgeschehen das wahre
krankheitsgeschehen für unsere
mitmenschen unterschätzen und das risiko
müssen wir schon richtig einschätzen und
auch fakten bewerten können zu der zahl
der durchgeführten schnell und
selbsttests da der bund ja nicht
geschafft und verteilt sondern
selbstständig ins kontor bei den selber
den schnelltests die ja mehr als genug
verfügbar sind bestellt wird in den
arztpraxen in den apotheken die die
tests durchführen in den testzentren die
tests durchführen haben wir keinen
abschließenden überblick darüber wie
viele tests in der letzten woche gemacht
worden sind wir werden das zeitversetzt
an den abrechnungen sehen aber die
kommen eben sehr zeitversetzt und da wo
positiv getestet wird jetzt soll es ja
und den testzentren in den arztpraxen
wird es ja auch passieren eine pcr
bestätigungstest umgeben und daran sehen
wir dann eben die tatsächliche
entwicklung bei den positiv test dann
machen wir im saal weiterhin kreutzfeldt
links von unseres gesehen
ich habe ja nur gesagt dass wir
tatsächlich nicht täglich die meldung
bekommen geht ja auch gar nicht sind ja
nicht alle in einem zentralen register
und finden auch nicht alle in
testzentren statt
ich finde schnelltests oder nächster
schritt selbst test in deutschland
stattfinden das machen die menschen ja
im zweifel zu hause in ihrer
privatwohnung diesen selbst test in
selbstverantwortung und darüber haben
wir natürlich gern den abschließenden
überblick wer sich wie selbst testet an
der stelle
was dann passiert und unsere
ausdrückliche empfehlung ist bei den
schnelltest witz regelhaft passieren in
den tests zentren und den arztpraxen und
bei dem selbsttest ist die ausdrückliche
empfehlung sich zu wenden bei einem
positiven testergebnis an den arzt ein
11 6 11 7 um eine pcr bestätigungstest
um zu veranlassen
dann natürlich sehen wir die zahl der
tatsächlich positiv getesteten dass es
insgesamt auch ein aus leuchtender
dunkelziffer ist wenn sie mehr testen
das ist ja ohne zweifel so wenn mehr
getestet wird und auch vor allem bei
asymptomatischen mehr getestet wird
werden sie im zweifel auch tatsächlich
fälle infektionen die sie sonst gar
nicht entdeckt hätten entdecken
deswegen ist die gesamt einordnung
wichtig und deswegen ist das wichtig was
der professor wieder gesagt hat dass wir
die anderen werkzeuge die wir haben die
sentinel praxen wie entwickeln sich
atemwegserkrankungen und das ist eine
gleichbleibende größe jetzt über monate
die wir da haben wir entwickeln sich
dort die zahlen entwickeln sich wie
entwickelt sich der behandlungsbedarf
dass wir all diese dinge parallel
beobachten aber eines war immer klar das
muss man auch einfach so aussprechen um
so mehr wie schnell und selbsttests
haben desto weniger können wir natürlich
am ende
abschließend sagen wie viele tests am
tag stattfinden und das alles
nachvollziehen das ist sozusagen das ist
die diskussion die wir mal wieder
miteinander geführt haben wie ist die
richtige balance wenn man nur labortests
machen haben waren super überblick aber
begrenzte kapazitäten und im zweifel
auch eine gewisse dunkelziffer
wenn wir nur selbst hätten wir gar
keinen überblick außer vielleicht bei
denen die sich dann melden
und wir müssen eben deswegen das immer
ergänzen mit weiteren instrumenten und
den bürgerinnen und bürgern genauso
sagen umso mehr es schnell und selbst es
gibt desto mehr ist die verantwortung
auch beim einzelnen gerade selbst test
heißt immer auch selbst verantwortung
ja das ist ja der grund für die
selbsttests also der bin ich jetzt von
der strategie der bekämpfungsstrategie
ausgehe dann sind die selbsttests die
nun verfügbar sind ihr ein weiteres
werkzeug was zu haben und es ist
selbstverständlich dass durch die
selbsttests die dunkelziffer sinken wird
wir werden ja mehr fälle ermitteln
dadurch das ist keine frage
und das wollen wir ja auch weil je
früher für einen menschen identifizieren
und auch wenn er falsch positiv getestet
ist es ja besser was er falsch positiv
getestet ist dann lieber zu hause bleibt
dann nach getestet wird mit der pca wenn
diese person dann aktiv noch andere
warnt dann kommen wir vor das geschehen
wir müssen ja diesen zeitraum bis das
gesundheitsamt überhaupt ins spiel
kommen und seine arbeit machen kann den
zeitungen können nur wir selber
verringern
das heißt also dieses zusätzliche mittel
wird dazu führen natürlich dass die
dunkelziffer geringer wird aber ich will
es noch mal sagen weil die diskussion
immer wieder kommt wenn der eindruck
entsteht dass ist künstliche erhöhung
von fallzahlen gäbe dann bitte ich
einfach nochmal alle die menschen die
das immer wieder rekurrieren auf die
klinischen daten zu schauen und
schlichtweg nicht bewusst zu sein dass
diese krankheit zu schweren verläufen
führt zu todesfällen führen kann
und je früher wir einen positiv getestet
und dann wirklich infektiösen aus dem
verkehr ziehen desto größer ist die
chance dass andere
geschützt werden und das ist das
zentrale ziel von testungen ja und darum
bei aller wir haben oft darüber wird man
kann das ruhig sagen auch akademisch
gestritten wie gut sind diese
selbsttests eigentlich wie viel falsch
positive werden wir haben wir haben dazu
publikationen geschrieben es gibt eine
reihe falsch positive aber dann sollen
die leute eben nach testen und dann wird
man sehen was richtig positiv gewesen
ist das ziel
lieber einen zu viel zu erkennen als
einen zu wenig ist ein hohes wertvolles
ziel um diese pandemie zu bekämpfen ja
und das ist der entscheidende punkt wir
nehmen hier eine gewisse schwäche dieses
tests mit aber mit klugen konzepten
nutzen wir damit der gesamten
bevölkerung dazu nehme ich nochmal weise
grad passt eine frage von markus grill
ndr wdr fragt sie hier wieder wie viele
pcr tests werden derzeit durchgeführt
weil zuvor ein schnelltest positiv
ausgefallen ist und wie viele dieser pc
erscheinen dann ebenfalls positiv aus
habe ich nicht im kopf die daten kommen
wir aber im robert-koch-institut die
kann der bitte bei der pressestelle nach
vorn ich habe sie nicht im kopf sie
können das auch das ein hinweis gerne an
uns weiterleiten dann geben wir das auch
gerne bei den verteiler weiter dann
können wir das nach liefern dann machen
wir im saal weiter bei frau pauli
[Musik]
vielleicht kann sogar vor richter scheer
auch noch mal aus dem alltag mit das
massaker berichten dazu aber erst mal
was mir sehr wichtigen ist wir nehmen
die meldung sehr sehr ernst und bewerten
sie natürlich sofort und bieten sowohl
die europäischen arzneimittelbehörden
wie das paul-ehrlich-institut in der
bewertung vorzunehmen die findet auch
hat stattgefunden und findet natürlich
weiter statt
die europäische arzneimittelagentur hat
nach beratung der experten gestern
erklärt dass es keine auffällige häufung
von thrombosen im zeitlichen
zusammenhang mit der impfung gebe das
paul ehrlich institut analysiert die
lage parallel und kommt auch für
deutschland zu derselben einschätzung
aber natürlich wird es tag um tag gerade
jetzt mit blick auf diese frage sehr
genau betrachtet ich bedauere ist dass
auf dieser grundlage wissenstand jetzt
freitag vormittag einige länder in der
europäischen union das impfen mit astra
zenica ausgesetzt haben die allermeisten
übrigens nicht weil sie eben der
empfehlung der zuständigen behörden und
der experten folgen und der einschätzung
was ich sehr wichtig finde ist wir
müssen die richtige balance finden
zwischen der aufmerksamkeit dem sehr
ernst nehmen solche meldungen begehen
dem unmittelbar nach auffinden obduktion
statt das paul ehrlich institut
begleitet das intensiv mit den behörden
vor ort um zu erkennen ob das ist ja die
frage
das einen kausalen zusammenhang oder ist
es nur in anführungszeichen ein
zeitlicher zusammenhang der statistisch
natürlich sich ergeben können wenn sie 3
15 millionen menschen impfen mit einem
impfstoff wird statistisch bestimmte
erkrankungen die auch sonst drei fünf
oder zehn millionen menschen ohne
impfung hätten dann auch im zeitlichen
zusammenhang auftauchen die frage ist
gibt es einen ursächlichen zusammenhang
und dafür das sagen uns das
paul-ehrlich-institut wie die
europäischen behörden das sagt übrigens
selbst die behörden bisher in den
ländern die ausgesetzt haben gibt es
keinen hinweis stand jetzt freitag
vormittag und deswegen ist diese balance
so wichtig zwischen aufmerksam sein und
nicht nicht alarm machen
das ist ja die frage die sie auch mit
angesprochen haben wir sind aufmerksam
begleiten auf transparenz das paul
ehrlich institut veröffentlicht jede
woche die meldungen die es auch gibt im
zusammenhang mit der mit den impfungen
und zwar nicht nur im fraktionen sondern
eben auch folgewirkungen die erstmal
einen zeitlichen zusammenhang stehen und
geht dem intensiv nach wie andere
behörden auch also wir machen das sehr
transparent sehr sehr offen
aber ich finde wir haben auch eine
gemeinsame verantwortung wenn ich das
sagen darf dass entsprechend einzuordnen
weil die transparenz voraussetzung ist
für akzeptanz und gleichzeitig aber eben
aus der transparenz finde ich dann auch
nichts entstehen darf was dann
fälschlicherweise akzeptanz reduzieren
würde
und mit dem was wir bisher wissen ist
der nutzen auch nach allen vorfällen die
bisher berichtet untersucht wurden bei
weitem höher als das risiko und das gilt
auch weiterhin
ich kann da nicht viel mehr zu sagen ich
möchte aber zwei antworten geben erstens
wir haben uns in deutschland ganz
bewusst dafür entschieden diese
impfstoffe erst zuzulassen nachdem die
behörden alle unterlagen entsprechend
geprüft haben wir haben in deutschland
keine not zulassung zugelassen genau um
alle informationen die den behörden zur
verfügung stehen zu nutzen und so viel
wie möglich mit dem jeweiligen wissen
was
unten ist eine sicherheit zu haben das
ist der eine aspekt der zweite aspekt
ist der wir machen in deutschland
mehrere studien über gleiten das sehr
eng sowohl vom robert-koch-institut als
auch vom paul-ehrlich-institut ii
studien hatte ich auch schon in diesem
rahmen hier mehrfach genannt genau um
ein monitoring zu haben was denn alles
beobachtet wird damit wir das wissen
und wir müssen folgendes wissen das
hatte ich auch schon mal ich glaube
sogar in dieser runde hier gesagt in
deutschland sterben ja statistisch
gesehen im schnitt zu 900.000 menschen
jedes jahr sterben in deutschland und
das ist nun mal so das leben gehört zu
unserem der tod gehört zu unserem leben
dazu und natürlich wenn wir jetzt sehr
viele sehr alte und hochaltrigen
menschen impfen dann ist natürlich klar
die meisten menschen die in deutschland
sterben sind natürlich hochaltrigen und
alte menschen und dann kann es auch da
zeitlich einen zusammenhang geben
zwischen einer impfung und einem toten
ist eine reine statistik das braucht man
nur zu berechnen und genauso wie alle
anderen krankheiten und darum geht es
genau
das genau zu beobachten zu analysieren
und der entscheidende punkt ist dann zu
sagen ist es ein ursächlicher
zusammenhang oder ein zeitlicher und den
zeitlichen wird es häufig geben mit
vielen verschiedenen krankheiten und das
genau der grund warum dann die person
weder an krankheiten hatten oder
vielleicht sogar verstorben sind in
zeiten zusammen obduziert wenn und
nachgeschaut wird und in den jetzigen
zeitpunkt gibt es keinen hinweis dass
diese geschehnisse statistisch auffällig
wären aber das wird weiter untersucht
und meine damen und herren das ist auch
ein grund warum wir die impfzentren so
intensiv brauchen weil die ganze
dokumentation die gerade am anfang läuft
die ersten millionen die wir impfen das
sind ja ganz viele menschen wo wir ganz
viele informationen gewinnen
es ist natürlich klar und verrichtet er
hat darauf hingewiesen die ganze
dokumentation ist natürlich so aufwendig
die geht im impfzentrum natürlich
einfacher wird eine große logistik ist
und aus diesen informationen kommt ja
dann das wissen zb über diese fälle weil
das doch eben systematisch
fast wird und das ist übrigens auch ein
grund warum die impfzentren von
besonderer wert wirklich die wichtigkeit
sind
wir wollen alle fakten so transparent
wie möglich an die leute bringen damit
klar ist was dort geschieht richter
schere vor sie antworten würde ich
vielleicht noch eine frage sogar mit
dazufügen von der kollegin polona vier
jahre slowenisches fernsehen die sich
auch nach nebenwirkungen akku nicht
unter zu fragt haben sie spezielle
verfahren dass sie etwa nur einen
bestimmten prozentsatz von lehrern oder
ärzten eines ortes am selben tag in
vielen dank also ergänzend den
vorrednern kann ich das auch eigentlich
nur sagen wir haben gestern als das im
radio kam hatte ich auch prompt eine
eine endfällige die ganz aufrecht war
muss ich jetzt den astra nehmen will ich
nicht und aber auch da konnte man mit
sachargumenten wie eben gerade im
vorfeld genannt wurden konnte man da
schon sehr gut argumentieren und der
nachmittag war relativ ruhig wie es
jetzt heute ist weiß ich nicht weil ich
hier sitze
das bekomme ich noch aus aber auch
grundsätzlich stimme ich dem ja auch zu
ich werde weiterhin den astra zenica
solange eben es wissenschaftlich nichts
anderes man anderes nichts hört werde
ich den asta zenica empfehlen
im vergleich zu den bei und taekwondo
ist auch darauf eingehen sind für mich
die impfstoffe im rahmen dessen dass wir
alle menschen so schnell wie möglich
durch ihn sollen auf jeden fall gleich
fertig und dann zu den imf reaktionen
ich sag ja mal wenn ein patient sagt ich
habe angst vor den nebenwirkungen es hat
welche nebenwirkungen meinen sie ich
sage ich kenne nur im reaktionen das ist
schon immer mal was anderes
denn damit kann man die patienten
positiv abholen dass man einfach sagt
mensch oder froh dass er in fraktion
muss zwar nicht so heftig sein
ja aber sie wissen dass der impfstoff
auf jeden fall eine immunantwort in
ihrem körper auslöst also damit kann man
sehr viele menschen ab und auch die
zweite frage dazu ja das ist richtig
wenn wir eben verschiedene berufsgruppen
impfen das läuft mittlerweile
erfahrungsgemäß wirklich über zwei tage
über zwei verschiedene termine um eben
nicht ausfälle beruflicher natur an
tag zu haben wobei erfahrungsgemäß jetzt
gesagt wird die impfreaktion sind im
vergleich das was mit den patienten
sagen das sind im vergleich zu dem band
im stoff relativ wenig wesentlich kürzer
also mann berichtet immer bei uns nur
von fünf bis zehn stunden
das eben enorme grieder muskelschmerzen
und auch temperatur entwicklung da sind
und bei dem zweiten impfstoff wird nach
der zweiten impfung sogar einige
kollegen von mir hat es erwischt er am
24 stunden fest im bett gelegen und
sagten ich wusste nicht dass wieder
schmerzen so extrem sein konnten also
ich sag auch da tun sich in den
installationen letztendlich die beiden
impfstoffe nichts dann machen wir im
saal weiter bei herrn jung
ja jungherr jungen wir hatten am anfang
vereinbart aus fairnessgründen eine
frage das waren jetzt zwei es haben mehr
erstens mache ich hier die regeln sie
hatten jetzt zwei fragen die werden
beide beantwortet und damit ist dann
aber der nächste dran also zuerst einmal
möchte ich auch noch mal erinnern an die
situation in der wir waren vor zwölf
monaten als unikliniken sagten und auch
viele andere im gesundheitswesen wenn
nicht bald sehr bald masken kommen
werden wir den betrieb einstellen müssen
wir haben darüber gesprochen und sogar
empfehlungen erarbeitet zwischen unseren
behörden was das wiederverwerten von ffw
zwei masken angeht braucht man sie bei
hitze sterilisieren kann wieder nur ein
anderes mehr so groß war die not und
natürlich haben wir zu beginn dann auch
ja kein europäisches vergabeverfahren
über drei oder sechs monate gemachte
stimmt weil wir einfach handeln mussten
wenn ich die wahl habe dafür zu sorgen
dass nächste woche ärztinnen und ärzte
und pflegekräfte masken haben oder eben
ein verfahren von sechs monaten
einzuhalten entscheide ich mich in einer
pandemie und in der not dafür schnell zu
handeln
das ist so ich habe übrigens diskussion
damals so sind ja meistens händler
weil ja gar keine hersteller händler
auch in fernsehsendungen gesagt haben
ich habe der minister eine e mail
geschrieben
der hat mir gar nicht geantwortet und
alle in der sendung haben gesagt wir
hatten gar nicht geantwortet er hat sich
nicht leicht bei ihnen gemeldet
und jetzt ist die frage auf einmal warum
hat der minister selbst auch in diesen
ersten tagen mitgeholfen das gleiche
passiert jetzt gerade bei schnell und
selbsttests die situation ist nicht
vergleichbar ganz die lage ist nicht so
ernst in der versorgung aber gerade zu
beginn wenn etwas sehr sehr knapp ist
engagieren wir uns alle im
bundesministerium für gesundheit um
einen unterschied zu machen und das ist
jetzt auch sehr wichtig zu sehen
bei der bewertung bei den abgeordneten
erst mal halte ich doch für ziemlich
normal dass dann wenn jemand einen
hinweis bekommen darauf dass masken
verfügbar sein
das ist ein anbieter gibt dass das dann
weitergeleitet wird
und der hinweis gegeben wird oder wenn
sich jemand aus dem wahlkreis meldet und
sagt da ist was wir könnten unterstützen
dass man das weiter leitet das würde ich
sogar erwarten erwartet haben in der
damaligen situation und davon deutlich
zu unterscheiden ist alles was mit
bestechung korruption vorteilsnahme zu
tun hat ist ein ganz entscheidender
unterschied und ich werbe auch sehr
dafür diesen unterschied in der
öffentlichen debatte zu machen und die
alle aller allermeisten kolleginnen und
kollegen am schlicht und ergreifend das
getan was viele andere bürger landräte
abgeholte aus anderen parlamenten auch
gemacht haben hinweise die sie erreicht
haben was helfen könnte in der not
weiterzuleiten
das sage ich noch einmal bitte ich zu
unterscheiden und genau vor diesem
hintergrund müssen wir jetzt sehr genau
schauen wie wir damit umgehen weil ich
nicht finde das einfach nur so zu sagen
weil jemanden e mail weitergeleitet hat
und hinweis gegeben hat da gleich alles
in einen topf geschmissen wird und
deswegen werden wir der bundestag hat
uns ja den hinweis gegeben
richtigerweise dass das nur mit
einwilligung der betroffenen geht eine
entsprechende veröffentlichung sind wir
grad in einem prozess zu überlegen wie
man das am besten macht um das
berechtigte interesse nach transparenz
auch entgegenkommen zu können und
gleichzeitig die rechte der einzelnen
auch beachten zu können
das was ich gerade gesagt habe zu den
masken gilt am ende auch für die
logistik
da haben wir kurzfristig und die
unterlagen sind ja alle da sind ja
mittlerweile sogar öffentlich können sie
ja nachvollziehen herr jung wie die
vergabeentscheidung in diesen fragen
getroffen worden sind und auch da haben
wir sehr zügig dann nachgezogen
ich würde mal sagen es geht dabei nicht
was haben sie gesagt milliarden-aufträge
wenn wir einmal genau hinschauen der
teuerste teil dessen damals war die
luftfracht luftfracht war richtig teuer
damals der flug von china nach
deutschland und ein ganz ganz großer
teil der logistikkosten waren die
luftfracht kosten die eins zu eins
durchgereicht worden sind
und deswegen bitte ich auch immer bei
summen aller art vielleicht nochmal zu
unterscheiden was wofür aufgewendet
wurde
immer kurz erwartungsmanagement zu
betreiben ich habe hier auf der liste
noch glaube ich mindestens zehn leute
und online viele fragen zum thema impfen
die ich auf jeden fall noch gerne
annehmen würde mache jetzt hier erstmal
noch bei einer frage im saal weiter
herr jordan aus infektions medizinischer
sicht
ich denke das haben alle in den letzten
wochen monaten immer klar gemacht wäre
natürlich eine schließung ein guter weg
aber diese abwägung die getroffen wird
ist ja nachvollziehbar und sie ist gut
begründet was wir ganz konkret immer
gesagt haben und das haben ja alle die
in der verantwortung stehen immer gesagt
wir müssen kluge konzepte umsetzen
es gibt konzepte ich bin mir jetzt nicht
mehr sicher waren das
robert-koch-institut zum ersten mal eins
geschrieben hat aber es ist ja
irgendwann im sommer gewesen
für die schulen wir haben immer gesagt
dass man schulen öffnen sollte ja aber
mit klugen klaren konzepten und ich gehe
davon aus dass in den letzten monaten
diese konzepte erarbeitet wurden und
vorhanden sind das heißt also man kann
schützen man kann mit guten konzepten
arbeit man kann mit guten test konzepten
arbeiten man kann mit guten masken tage
konzepten arbeiten und so weiter und so
fort das heißt also das ist eine
abwägung geben nicht nur noch infektions
medizinisch bedingt ist das wissen wir
alle und das ist jetzt eben die
situation wo wir uns die frage stellen
müssen wie gut können wir schützen
und ich sage nochmal wir haben den
werkzeugkasten ihrem selbsttests wir
haben anti gen tests wir haben masken
wir haben die gene richtlinien wir haben
möglichkeiten gruppierungen zu bilden
wir haben möglichkeiten sogenannte
soziale social babbels zu bilden gruppen
die fest zu einander finden das gibt es
alles das muss dann einfach umgesetzt
werden und das kann auch umgesetzt
werden es wird nicht hundert prozent
schützen ja aber wir können durch
konzepte durch chlor konzept und
verhalten den infektions die infektions
verbreitung zumindest zu einem großen
teil
ich bin nur kurz ergänzen wir haben
immer gesagt dass gesundheitsschutz
infektionsschutz sehr sehr wichtig ist
aber nicht absolut und das ist ja gerade
das schwierige mit blick auf kitas und
schulen weil wir gleichzeitig
richtigerweise eine debatte darüber
haben was macht das eigentlich mit
kindern und jugendlichen wenn sie über
so viele monate nicht in kitas und
schulen gehen können wo auch nicht in
jedem fall das elternhaus einspringen
kann oder will
was bildung erziehung manchmal sogar das
warme mittagessen angeht
und deswegen muss man das ja schon auch
sehr abwägen auch welche folgen das
nicht öffnen von kitas und schulen auch
für die gesundheit von kindern und
jugendlichen und für ihr auch seelisches
wohlbefinden hat das waren ja sehr sehr
harte zeiten und sind es zum teil noch
für eltern wie für die kinder
und keiner von uns weiß doch was das
eigentlich zum kleinen menschen macht
den letzten monate jemand der sechs
jahre alt ist ein kind halt ein sechstel
seines lebens grad in der pandemie
verbrauchen
deswegen ist das schon eine abwägung
zwischen absoluten infektionsschutz den
wir eben nicht absolut stellen hat
zwischen den infektionen schutz
bestmöglich und denen was auch die
sonstigen lebensbereiche erfordern
deswegen ist es wichtig wie er professor
wieder gesagt hat das ist konzepte gibt
um den schutz zu erhöhen
ob's wechsel unterricht und andere sind
die selbsttests die jetzt helfen können
zusätzliche sicherheit zu geben übrigens
auch das impfen gerade in den bei den
erzieherinnen und erziehern und
grundschullehrern und grundschullehrern
findet ja gerade stadt auch um
zusätzliche sicherheit zusätzlichen
schutz zu geben am ende ist das eben das
wichtige dass das zu sehen dass
abzuwägen und deswegen war es aus meiner
sicht auch so wichtig diese zwei wochen
schritte zu gehen weil 1 ist eben auch
warm ich das noch hinzufügen darf kitas
und schulen öffnen setzt natürlich mit
am meisten bewegung von allen maßnahmen
in sozusagen in setzt in bewegung die
meisten von allen maßnahmen wenn sie
wenn sie das vergleichen weil natürlich
millionen zur schule und zurück und sie
begegnen sich deswegen ist es halt sehr
wichtig nach jedem schritt den wir gehen
auch den vereinbarten zwei wochen
rhythmus immer zuschauen weil ich hier
folgen hat das
und das muss man jetzt das was der
professor wieder als beobachtung
jetzt im vernünftig auswerten und in
einen zusammenhang stellen für alle
entscheidungen die anstehen dann würde
ich jetzt noch mal das zum thema impfen
kommen wir dazu online vor allen dingen
viele fragen eingegangen sind es gibt
fragen von kollegen die da geht es um
den start der impfungen den arztpraxen
bernhard walter von der badischen
zeitung fragt sie ersparen
wie bewerten sie es dass bayern am
ersten april mit den impfungen in den
praxen starten will
ähnliche frage von kollegen tim sandy
waren die redaktions netzwerk
deutschland er fragt warum erst mitte
april
es gebe doch vorher schon genügend dosen
da bleibe doch genug für die praxen
übrig und eine frage würde ich dann auch
noch mit rein nehmen die richtet sich an
frau richter scheer von sascha meyer dpa
wie schnell werden impfzentren nicht
mehr gebraucht oder sollten die aus
ihrer sicht weiter betrieben werden auch
wenn die praxen impfen
also zuerst einmal wie gesagt ich war
gestern selbst beim start eines
modellprojekts sie in berlin in einer
arztpraxis die eben mit impfen schon
begonnen hat ist in fast allen
bundesländern auch auf basis der
verordnung die ich diese woche
unterzeichnet habe jetzt modellhaft als
modellhaft binden länder arztpraxen in
die impfkampagne mit ein das passiert
auch nicht erst anfang april das ist in
vielen ländern schon passiert ob in
vorpommern
ob in hamburg ob im saarland oder eben
hier in berlin wir haben die
vergütungsfragen dazu geregelt im
übrigen auch die melde fragen geregelt
mit reduzierten meldedaten setzen dann
aus den aus den arztpraxen so dass das
so zu sagen jetzt ein fließender
übergang ist wir haben ausdrücklich
gesagt die länder sollen jetzt in einem
ersten schritt arztpraxen mit einbinden
etwa um zum beispiel onkologische praxis
und krebspatienten auch von dem eigenen
behandelnden arzt impfen lassen zu
können
er weiß am besten bescheid das haben sie
ja gerade auch deutlich gemacht habe ich
das ja und dann ist die nächste frage
eben dann geht es routinemäßig und wann
vor allem auch die logistik die ich
gerade beschrieben habe der ganze
mechanismus wenn sie es einmal machen
dann sind vielleicht 50 bis 70.000
empfinde arztpraxen
wenn sie fragen warum 50 bis 70
1000 weil wir nicht wissen wie viele
mitmachen wollen aber mitmachen könnten
wenn wir schauen wer macht in
deutschland überhaupt schutzimpfung
regelmäßig sind das etwa 270 80.000
arztpraxen in deutschland davon gut
50.000 hausarztpraxen und die frage oder
dieser schritt der ist eben ein sehr
sehr großer nur rechnen wenn 50.000
arztpraxen mitmachen 20 dosen die woche
sind schon eine million dosen 20 dosen
die woche reicht mal gerade dann für
eine impf sprechstunden in der woche und
das braucht eben eine gewisse ein
gewisses mindestvolumen und wenn die
länder gleichzeitig sagen und das war
die diskussion am mittwoch die grundlast
in den impfzentren im april soll 2,25
millionen impfungen pro woche sein
wir haben einen niedrigeren wert
vorgeschlagen
aber die einigung war am ende 2,25
millionen in den impfzentren pro woche
dann leitet sich eben die frage was ist
wann macht es sinn in die hausarzt in
die arztpraxen zu wechseln daraus ab
wenn deutlich mehr menge als erwartet
früher kommen sollte wenn wir den
schritt früher gehen können es hängt
auch immer zusammen ich weiß auch noch
nicht abschließen muss man mal sagen wir
wissen noch nicht abschließend leider
von allen herstellern alle lieferdaten
im nächsten monat ich hätte sie gerne
von bayern begrüßen wir es und allen
anderen noch nicht sicher und deren